Jay Bilas ESPN college basketball
analyst got the draft coming up tomorrow
night and you know when I first thought
about having Jay on Jay sent out a tweet
earlier this morning and it had to do
with Len Bias on this day in 1986 the
great Len Bias died he was one of the
greatest players I had ever seen simply
amazing Superman on the floor and Jay
was I believe at Duke still at that time
when you faced Len Bias Jay kind enough
to join us what do you remember about
Len Bias the player well we were in the
same class so we graduated the same year
played four years against one another
and he was friendly with a few of the
players on my team with Johnny Dawkins
Tommy Amica all grew up in the DC area
and I remember him being Superman
honestly and he was unstoppable
had a just a spectacular athlete with a
chiseled body and he could really shoot
it he was a great jump shooter and in a
two-footed leaper you know I think a lot
of people remember I think I think they
were Maryland was the first team to beat
North Carolina in the Dean Dome or that
just opened up we played the first game
in there but they were the first team to
win and he had yet scored a bucket and
made a steal and a reverse reverse dunk
that you know he did stuff that was
iconic and there were three players in
the ACC back then that I felt were
better than anybody one was Jordan
Michael Jordan
the second was Ralph Sampson and the
third was Len Bias
that's how good he was and I mentioned
earlier in the show I covered that 1986
draft and I remember Lenny had that
white suit on he had a big smile on his
face and you bring up the he was great
jumping off two feet Dominic Wilkins was
that way there's certain you know
leapers who were great off two feet and
I said I know that you know people might
try to make the comparison of you know
bias and Zion Williamson but Lenny was
more of a finished product he was a
better jump shooter he was equally as
explosive here but it is interesting
that we're looking at Zion did we lose
Jay
princey no see if we can locate J that
was a big build-up to my next question
there you are the role I was it was on a
big role there great setup yeah was
hammer quite I know that's where you
want to Sports Emmy right there
well that that question and then we have
to remove J's question from hello or its
J saying hello no no J would have said I
had a big build up there J and then you
dropped a hello so it kind of lost its
impact but my bad I was talking about
how you know that I could look at
comparisons even though that Lenny was
more of a finished product and a better
jump shooter than Zion but you know
we're looking at these explosive guys
coming into the league and we were
talking about is there a way that Sion
can be a disappointment because he can't
live up to what our expectation level is
of him he could still have a great
career and still not live up to what we
think he should be yeah I guess only if
it gets hurt is the thing that I would
say look he's not is not the shooter
that Len Bias was but he's done things
he's the type of player I've never seen
anybody like him and you can't take your
eyes off on the easy he's way more
explosive the bias was way bigger it's
remarkable
I mean he's got the best player
efficiency rating that we've seen since
they've been keeping this stuff and that
includes guys like Anthony Davis just
because he's a better better score
but what Zions gonna be great I don't
have any doubt about that as long as he
stays healthy when I was mentioning that
he could be a left-handed Blake Griffin
yeah maybe I think I actually think he's
a little bit better than that but but
we'll see I mean you know look I don't
think Blake Griffin did the things that
society
Sian's a far better passer Blake Griffin
didn't block shots like he didn't get
steals like he did mhm
you know certainly athletically when you
when he gets near the basket but but you
know he didn't put up those kind
numbers and Griffin was great but I have
a different different breed he he can
handle the ball he's a his IQ is off the
charts passing wise you know even
Griffin turned into a pretty good
shooter you know so I think Zion can get
there he's never going to be Steph Curry
or klay Thompson I'm not suggesting that
but he's going to he's going to be able
to make a consistently a standstill
jumper and and even got better as the
season went along but he's just got this
it quality about him and you know when I
saw him playing Canada I'd seen
everything in high school wants to play
all that stuff but it didn't resonate
with me like it did once I saw him at
cameras that clean it gets been over the
summer and you going man this is
different and I remember calling folks
at ESPN say we better gear up for this
because this is this is different and we
better have a camera on him and warmups
because players can Duncan or muffs now
at college the the the n-c-double-a has
given up on their mamas attitude about
that's like break a rift but but you
know you want to have a camera on him in
warm-ups because he's going to do things
that you just haven't seen is there a
chance that John Moran is a better Pro
of course yeah and that's the one thing
all these years Dan you've been doing
longer made but because you're much
older but the one thing that I've
learned over the years is we are going
to be wrong and we're gonna miss out on
guys like we were nobody knew Kawhi
Leonard was going to be this good nobody
knew that draymond Green was going to be
this good nobody saw Pascal siakam gonna
be this all this stuff so you know just
because we know what that we believe we
know what the draft order is and then we
get locked into our mind said okay this
is where everybody's ceiling is we don't
know and that's kind of I've come to
take that as the beauty of it that I
almost enjoy talking about the guys I
was wrong on or the ones you're right on
because it's it's it's fun as hell to go
through this process and but I do I
often times like I'll look at the NFL
Draft to go back and look at where
players were projected what was expected
of them and and what I found is that the
NFL makes as many if not more mistakes
within the end
on draft and and they have five years to
look at those guys it's it's an inexact
science and it's not you I don't know
you can't even call it a science it's
probably more more of an art and you
just try to get as much information as
you can so you make the best possible
decision but you can't you know you you
have to accept that guys are gonna guys
are going to come come out of nowhere
and explode and be better or worse than
you thought
who was your biggest whiff you thought
was gonna be great didn't turn out to be
I lose you again Jay hello bring bring
his phone is this bill is his phone
hello disconnected again oh that was
another great question I'm dying to know
who some how would I ask these tough
questions his phone goes down maybe he's
not used to his phone's not used to
hearing good questions on interviews Wow
no don't do that just no we're good with
the mothership great no everything is
good kumbaya bye Jay do you want to play
the Jay Bilas game okay what is the Jay
Bilas game is it Jay Jason or other cuz
he goes by Jay I mean well other anyone
else
I got either okay I'm going other - I
got JY straight-up
Jay's got the answer he gets back on
okay I think we gotta get just that drop
where Jay Bilas goes hello rich he's
working on Jay Bilas I put him in the
cone of silence I bet he would he's
gonna go with Mike Dunleavy as a guy he
got wrong I'm trying to think he loves
Duke guys try it again and fritzy is
brought back Jay Bilas Jay every time I
ask a good question which is an often
your phone somehow drops out yeah this
narcolepsy is killing me I'm getting
text messages while I'm trying to talk
on the phone but but I polish
okay I got two more questions for you
and one is the biggest whiff you had on
a draft pick was who the biggest
worthless Dwight Howard that back was
that was the second year I was doing
this after the LeBron draft and I was
still in the old school thought of wait
a minute now high school players come on
you know and I I thought he was
unskilled and I was unsure that he would
become a skilled player but I didn't
account for his athleticism his
world-class athleticism trumping any
lack of skill and it trumped it so I
mean you'd look back on that going or
what an idiot how could I have how could
I have thought that he should be you
know maybe question him as the number
one pick but but I got over my my sort
of old-school bias against high school
players pretty quick after that Paulie
said that there we were playing a Jay
Bilas game here Jay would you listen up
Paulie will tell you the rules here
we're trying to guess you're Nader Jay
Jason or other your actual birth
certificate first name and I went other
McLovin went other fritzy went other
Seaton went Jay straight up and Paulie
already knows the answer so Jay could
you help it it is Jay straight up and I
have a middle name my middle name is
Scott with one T because my grandmother
on my mother's side emigrated from
Scotland so that was a clever way of
getting my driver's license to never be
right for the rest of my life
Jay thank you have fun at the draft
tomorrow night and it's always great to
talk to you it can't be fun without you
there Dan we have the most fun a guy
could have it grab but do you remember
when Steve and I Smith stopped talking
at the end of the first round with what
Portland was doing and he goes I don't
know what to say I don't know what the
Blazers are doing I think I got nothing
to say and I'm going you're you're the
analyst you gotta have something to say
do you remember that I do remember that
I also remember when my good friend Tom
Tolbert in the middle of something said
I've never heard of this guy I don't
even know why is prior to the draft that
draft Jay I had somebody come up and say
do you know about Brandon Roy and I go
what do you mean there's some teams that
don't know that that knee is shot and
they should not be taken Brandon right
is a another agent who told me this
prior to that draft
well I knew about that I knew that the
knee was an issue but but I was told it
was going to be a number of years before
before it would be you know sort of a
career-ending issue and and I ranked up
second overall that year that was one of
my few hits because he was an
extraordinary player he was he was
certainly worth the worth the risk
he's he's Jay Scott bilis jr. the third
Thank You Jay thank you guys great to be
late that's Jay Bilas hello hello ESPN
college basketball analyst Jay Bilas hey
well where did question thought out
weaving in history and the current
players of the game hello yes Fritzi
he's such a good guy he's feels
genuinely terrible that if someone was
kind of calling in and cutting him off
just some people you know but he's he
was truly bothered that that happened no
he basically ruin this segment hello
there's nothing worse though when you
ask that question and you think it's a
good question and then there's no answer
and then you realize you got like two
seconds where you go man he's really
thinking about this and then it gets to
the third second and then you go oh he's
not there for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR Live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]